greetings pilots let's discuss aircraft
or to be more exact their technical
specifications you'll know what affects
them and how to change them in your
hangar you will see main specifications
for each aircraft durability firepower
speed manoeuvrability and altitude
performance these statistics become
clear with numbers the more the better
but what do the horizontal marks below
the numbers mean they show how the
parameters of an aircraft's compared
with other aircraft of the same tier for
example the arado AR 80 in its top
configuration has a speed value of 388
graphically the value is displayed as
four and a half marks look at its
counterpart the tier 3 Soviet fighter I
16 early mod the speed value of the i-16
in its top configuration is 352 its
speed value is lower than that of the AR
80 so it only has four marks now let's
take a look at the speed of the il-4 TP
a soviet tier 10 attack aircraft it has
a speed of 767 km/h it greatly
outmatches both the i-16 and the AR 80
however it only has two horizontal marks
because other aircraft of its tier are
much faster so keep in mind that a
number value in the parameters is an
absolute value thus you can compare
specifications between every aircraft
using graphical values however you can
only compare aircraft of the same tier
keep in mind durability firepower speed
and maneuverability values are complex
they are formed with more narrow
parameters to view them expand them all
these characteristics are taken into
account in flight modelling and affect
the combat capabilities of an aircraft
however it may be difficult to
understand for beginner pilots but the
more you learn about each aircraft the
more important this information will be
it will help to analyze aircraft's pros
and cons more precisely let's compare
the i-16 late model and the focke-wulf
fw 57 in its stock configuration the
speed value of the jury
and heavy fighter is lower you may think
that this aircraft won't be able to
break away from the i-16 however let's
take a closer look at the detailed
parameters you can see that the maximum
dive speed value of the fw 57 is greater
so it can easily break away when diving
it would be hard to compare the specific
features of these aircraft and develop
in battle tactics for them without
knowing this additional information
let's take a look at the altitude
performance characteristic it shows at
what altitude an aircraft performs
optimally if your altitude performance
is greater than of the other aircraft of
the same tier it makes sense to attack
enemy aircraft from above using boom and
zoom tactics if your altitude
performance is low you should fly closer
to the ground you can change an
aircraft's specifications by mounting
new modules and equipment onto it to see
what you can upgrade choose an aircraft
from your hangar and open the upgrades
tab if you want to know the
characteristics of an engine or weapons
hover your mouse cursor over the icon
you can also right-click on the icon and
choose information if you left-click on
a module icon you will see that the
length of horizontal marks will change
and numbers will appear next to the
numerical values of the aircraft's main
specifications they show how
specifications will change after you
mount this much green numbers mean
specifications will improve while red
numbers mean they will comply mounted
modules are marked with yellow check you
can research new modules by spending
experience you earn in battles on a
particular aircraft as soon as you have
earned enough experience click on the
module and then click research to mount
a newly researched module you will need
to purchase it first if you have enough
credits left click on the module and
then click purchase and mount the old
module will be moved to the depot and
the new one will be mounted sometimes
you need to research a new airframe
first in order to mount a new engine or
autocannon
arrows in the scheme will show the
sequence of researching modules before
you sell an aircraft make sure you are
not going to use any modules mounted on
it in the future if you are replace them
so you do not have to purchase them
again in the tech tree tab you can
always learn specifications and
configurations of any in-game aircraft
you can also use the World of Warplanes
encyclopedia on the official website to
compare different aircraft this is a
useful tool for knowing your adversaries
better and planning further research
besides researching new modules you have
another option to improve the
performance of your aircraft in the
upgrades tab you will find three cells
to mount equipment click any cell to
view the list of equipment and its
characteristics these lists vary
depending on aircraft tier and type the
cost of equipment is displayed in each
cell as well as its name and description
if you don't have enough credits the
cost will be highlighted in red
otherwise you can purchase equipment
confirm mounting equipment by clicking
mount mounted equipment can change the
performance characteristics of an
aircraft however these changes aren't
included in the description of the
aircraft shown in your hangar you can
dismount equipment and then mount it
onto another aircraft if both aircraft
are compatible dismounting equipment may
cost a little or nothing at all for
example if you dismount gunsights to
sell equipment you don't need anymore
enter the store and choose the
corresponding section find the equipment
you no longer need and sell it
you can also use the store to purchase
equipment this is convenient if you want
to purchase equipment in larger
quantities that's all for now good luck
you
you